Silicon Valley in the deep state are
coming for conservative voices you know
this if last week you were in some sort
of hostage situation eyes pried open
forced to watch the democratic process
on c-span during the Capitol Hill
Facebook hearings two names kept popping
up dominant diamond and silk diamond and
silk two biological sisters from North
Carolina I might point out they're
african-american yes thank you for doing
that and I'm gonna guess you're the kind
of guy who always points that out yes
diamond and silk got mentioned a lot
last week as examples of conservative
speech getting silenced but who are
these two let's bring in diamond and
silk superfan Nicole Thurmond to tell us
more thank you so much Jordan Klepper
who I might point out is white thank you
my non-biological sister so who are
these ladies okay well they're boring
real names are Lynette Hardaway and
Rochelle Richardson but I know them and
love them as diamond and silk now if you
haven't seen these Trump loving YouTube
stars in action get ready
strap in and also turn your volume down
on your TV like six or seven notches now
I know that we're the land of the free
yeah but it doesn't mean for people to
come over here in our country illegally
or can I get free food education they
want to talk about his suite from
yesterday what he said to this one in
that one who you just caught back when
he's your president he's your president
huh you know what I'll tell you what
that is the kind of insight you can only
get from drinking a wine glass full of
Windex
these ladies are stars they got
everything they got energy hair net
choreography beverages that glow in the
dark and most importantly conservative
ideologies that are also a good time I
love them yeah where'd they Bend all my
life well I'll tell you what Jordan just
three years ago they were Democrats
gross mmm I mean who wants to watch that
I'll tell you what nobody does and as
they told Rolling Stone they probably
had like ten people watching their
channel which felt like a loss but then
someone came along who was all about
winning winning big lis and just like
that just like millions of poor white
people and 22 black people they got on
board the Trump train and they started
making videos defending yeah that's
smart
that's how you get those sweet sweet
clicks oh yeah that is diamond and silk
really broke through though in August
when megyn kelly had the gall to quote
Trump's own words back at him in a
presidential debate you've called women
you don't like fat pigs dogs slobs and
disgusting animals okay you are
disinvited from this living room megyn
kelly leave Donald Trump alone person
whose job it is to question a candidate
by megyn kelly hello 1.7 million YouTube
views now that's the kind of attention
that makes you say now whatever I just
did I'm making that my new thing the
next month they were saying that they
were Republicans faster than you can say
um is the answer Miami logo like really
about offensive
and they didn't just get on the Trump
train
they got Trump to get on theirs I turn
on my television one night and I see
these two on television I say they are
the greatest what is it they became an
internet sensation
I hope you've monetized you wanna do the
routine come on do a little routine come
on soft-shoe magic trick speak on behalf
of black people as proof that our
candidate is not a misogynist racist pig
girl Jesus token for you to ride the
Trump train and do it on my favorite
Network Fox News Trump is not a racist
he's a realist and the only color he
sees is green women already have
equality okay really
what are they marching for Hillary need
to start the she knew movement that's
because I'm quite sure she know about
her husband yes diamond and silk are
making America great again like it used
to be when everyone agreed that a
husband's infidelity was his wife's
fault no wonder why Fox loves them so
much they are like the hot sauce at the
all mayonnaise Fox barbeque list
we don't believe them nah you gotta love
them once you go that's right but don't
you come back don't come back we really
be telling the truth we're trying not to
be so funny but it comes down bunny I
like it you can have fun ladies you can
have fun and do politics and you do that
and I love it I'll tell you what you
know you made it when miss Laura gives
you permission to exist
I mean you saw all those white people
laughing at them with them at them with
them at them but it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter Jordan they are on TV and
me on TV is the only way to be okay
nicknack paddywhack give it off the bone
there were so many people yelling about
race stuff in America right now it's
very comforting for me to know the
biological sisters are on my side okay
baby your knowing you make me want to
shoot all thurman everyone the fights
today
[Applause]